what's up guys my name is the channel
welcome back to my game engine series
so last time we started upon the
adventure of creating a game of sorts
in hazel and to be honest still don't
know what on earth we're making
so if you have any suggestions just just
leave them in the comments below and
we'll talk more about that later
basically what we did last time was we
jammed in a particle system check out
that video if you haven't already so now
we have this kind of like
let's take a look at what we've got we
have this little demo here with a
particle system i'm running it in debug
mode so it's running a little bit slow
and in fact while we're at it maybe
let's turn down the particles so instead
of like
emitting 50 let's like emit five every
tick okay that's a little bit better
doesn't run
quite as badly my idea for this game so
far
is extremely vague we're going to make
kind of like a
top-down uh rpg style like stardew
valley
pokemon-esque zelda that kind of
game something that at least looks like
that because our goal here with hazel is
not exactly to try and make a game per
se although i
i am kind of open to that and i think
that'll be a good test
but we want to more or less test the
renderer so we've got a 2d renderer
i would like to render what is more or
less a realistic scene for a 2d game
because that's what we're working
towards this year i said for the game
engine series version of hazel's
like for the game engine series
effectively we are making we're focusing
on 2d so we want to create some kind of
like a you know our 2d render is pretty
much it's there
i mean there's obviously some other
things we could do and we will do but
so far it's capable of rendering like
textured quads
sprites that's what 2d games are made
out of and that's where this whole
like designing a test comes from so we
want a more or less realistic rendering
test
for a 2d game now there is of course the
interaction
side of everything and that's more to do
with like not necessarily
displaying everything not necessarily
rendering but the other half which is
like
all of your logic you know
anti-component system and we're gonna
get there eventually and lua you know
integrating scripting languages and
doing all of that without any c plus
plus our goal
basically for this year for sure
inside this current version of hazel the
2d version of hazel is i want to be able
to make
pretty much any 2d game in hazel without
touching c
plus plus or visual studio that's kind
of the idea and the all visual studio
part is going to make things a little
bit harder
but i've gone ahead and said that so
let's kind of aim for that but anyway
long story short for now
we need to build something and that's
what we're working towards now now i
kind of envisioned some kind of 2d
top-down zelda style game and that's
what we're going with
so the next logical step is to try and
actually build a level
we'll build the player and maybe the
animated sprites and all that stuff
later but for now i want to have some
sort of
level so the first step is getting some
assets we need to have assets to
actually render we can draw textured
quads just fine right now and we can
bash them all together and we can do all
this stuff
but we need some assets so let's go and
find some assets now of course i could
make some assets but this is not really
an art series so we're gonna just
consult kenny here who has just a bunch
of free game assets with
no strings attached so if we're going to
assets we can hopefully find something
here
that we can use so i'll just look
through this and maybe i'll find
something there's a whole bunch of 3d
models here that's another another
really cool thing to note
so when we actually do get around to
hazel 3d i think we will
also be consulting this and if you guys
want more of like an art series on how
to make
assets i mean i am more of a 3d artist
than a 2d artist but
if you want that let me know and i'll
i'll come up with something okay so
voxel pack could be pretty good even
though that's probably primarily for 3d
stuff but it doesn't matter i think
they're
textures i kind of like this map pack
but it's got a whole lot of stuff that
we don't really need let's see if we can
find anything better
rpg based that looks pretty much perfect
let's take a look at that
okay beautiful so it's got some
buildings trees okay let's grab this one
okay and now that we've got this let's
take a look so we've got them all as
separate pngs which is
nice but you can see there are a whole
bunch of them wow this is a big pack 220
229 that's quite a lot and then we have
them all as a sprite sheet so if we open
this up yeah perfect
okay so this is what we want and this is
actually what we're going to talk about
today
let's take a look at the sample yeah
that's beautiful okay so this is exactly
what we're going for this is the
aesthetic
i think this should be our next step now
i mentioned
sprite sheets and that's kind of what we
have in these packs a lot of these tile
based
fairly low resolution-ish like art
sets or games really will function on
sprite sheets or texture atlases meaning
what they do is they basically jam a
whole bunch of textures into one image
or one texture
and that has a lot of benefits for one
you might recall that our batch renderer
has a limit of 32 texture units or
texture slots that's pretty much
you know if we look at modern gpus
that's that's that's round about how
many textures you can bind
at any one time for one draw call you
can't really have
more than 32 textures bound i say you
can't really have because
technically you can but we're not going
to talk about that in the
traditional sense 32 textures is our
limit
you can see that we had like 220 or 229
i think
different textures or different tiles
within this
kind of pack if we had a scenario where
we wanted to render all of them at once
we could definitely do it but it means
that we have to split up our scene into
many many draw calls
so if we had like 128 different textures
and we were
somehow using all of them per draw that
would already be like four draw calls
so i want to i want to kind of emphasize
that that's not necessarily a problem
it's not like a huge deal for us to have
four draw calls a thousand draw calls is
probably getting up there
a hundred draw calls is totally fine so
don't stress too much about draw calls
that's not my intention with what i'm
saying
what i am saying though is it's very
impractical to have 200 different
textures
if we have 200 different texture assets
in hazel for every kind of tile
it's not good because we have to
constantly be binding rebinding textures
sorting them into draw calls
it's it's just very difficult and
they're so small these textures
that batching them together into one
texture just
ends up being a lot more efficient not
just for your gpu but for you
it's just easier to deal with so that's
why today we're going to be introducing
sprite sheets now i don't imagine we're
going to just
get them into hazel and come up with a
proper api all today
this is more of like an introduction
we'll probably continue this on
next episode but essentially what we're
going to do today is we're going to try
and render
something on the screen using these kind
of sprite sheets that we have
from this asset pack so coming back here
what we have let's take a look at this
sprite sheet one more time so there's
two there's this kind of normal one and
there's a 2x one i'm
sure i'm assuming it's just high
resolution let's grab this one so we
have rpg pack sheet
two times let's copy that i'm gonna
navigate to sandbox assets
and then textures we should probably
start splitting this off into a
different
game as well maybe if i go back maybe
we'll just make a new folder called game
and this is kind of the test game that
we're talking about here so we'll do
assets game and then within here you
know we'll have our folder called
textures and we'll put that in here just
to make it a little bit more organized
and we might do the same with the code
as well because i don't
really want this game to be part of like
sandbox
maybe because that should just be like a
quick test if this game ends up being
quite large i don't want it to be this
huge burden for people
uh so we essentially might just separate
it out but we'll see for now we'll keep
it in here so we have this sprite sheet
let's drop it into photoshop so that we
can take a closer look all right what do
we have here
okay so this is uh let me just make this
window
the correct size for you guys all right
so this is the asset pack
the reason i opened it in photoshop is
very simple we're not going to be
editing it or anything like that it's
just so that i can like
measure things basically so if we take a
look at one
of these tiles i mean what's a good
example maybe like this one here
you can see that it's it's i'm assuming
it's a power of two it's around about
128 pixels
by 128 pixels that is the size of these
sprites now to use this as a sprite
sheet meaning
to render a quad using just a portion of
this texture
is fairly straightforward all we need to
do is
set different texture coordinates for
our quad
instead of setting the typical kind of
zero to one
for both x and y which would mean the
the full texture which is what we've
been doing thus far
what we want to do instead is work out
what texture coordinates a
sub region of this texture would have so
in other words if we know that the
texture that we want to render like this
thing for example starts at 512
x and then maybe like 770 something y
we need to just simply convert that to a
range that's between zero and one
zero being the beginning of the texture
one being the end of the texture
in both the horizontal and vertical axes
and we basically have our little sub
region so in other words texture
coordinates are always going to be
between zero and one it's kind of like
normalizing the width and height of this
entire texture from pixels into this
kind of zero to one texture coordinate
space
we need to do that and that will allow
us to just kind of select a texture
or a sub region of this image to render
now it is going to be a lot simpler when
i actually show you guys how but the the
important thing for us to know
to to actually make this whole system
work is how big is each texture inside
this sprite sheet
in this case it's all really easy for us
because they are all pretty much the
same size i mean we do have things like
trees which
are double height uh compared to their
width but that's also fine
most of this is pretty simple we don't
really have a huge complex like
every sprite is different size they're
all just powers of two
all of them are 128 by 128 with some
exceptions
everything is going to be super simple
so we need the size of each
tile or each texture within the sprite
sheet as i mentioned and also the total
size
so we know that the width is 2560 and
the height here is
1664. all right that's important
information because what we're going to
do
is we're going to divide the width by
the size of each texture and that's
going to give us basically an index
and so if we know that a given texture
for example these stairs here
start at a particular pixel offset we
can just take that pixel offset so here
it's like 894
and divide it by the total width that's
going to give us a value of maybe around
0.3 to 0.4 for something like this
it's going to give us a value between 0
and 1 which is going to be our texture
coordinate and then we just need to kind
of track down
all four corner pins and set them to the
appropriate
texture coordinate for the appropriate
vertex that is it
it's quite simple so diving into hazel
let's first of all
load this so what i'll do is i'll come
over here and it's going to be again
this is more of an introductory episode
so i will just basically duplicate
the texture that we had here i'll call
this m sprite sheet
and i think i deleted the other one yep
i did um
sprite sheet then we're going to load
this sprite sheet so this will be
equals and then i will take this
assets game textures and then let's grab
the name of this
so rpg packsheet2x.png
let's pop that in here now we should
have the spritesheet loaded and if we
want to render
it let's just render it as a test i will
maybe
render it let's okay we have all this is
like our test scene let's start a new
scene
let's make it right before the particle
system i'm going to
do a begin scene and an end scene
and then if we come up here to draw quad
maybe the
checkerboard texture one let's just try
and draw a quad here we'll just draw it
at
zero zero maybe i'm gonna disable all of
this other stuff so that should help and
then we'll just
give it a size of one by one which of
course is not the aspect ratio of the
texture but that's okay
sprite sheet and then we can take away
the tiling factor there
okay cool um and let's maybe so this
stuff
i do ultimately want to keep this stuff
because it is kind of like our test i
just don't want it to render at this
given moment
so i'm just going to disable it by just
writing an if
zero and if all right so now that
stuff's disabled what we will do
probably next time is move all of this
game stuff into like an actual game
example
so i might even make a new project
called like game example and it might
even be external to the halo repository
um because sandbox should be internal to
this just for like like internal testing
and stuff like that
but um the game probably shouldn't be so
we'll we'll talk about that next time i
think
all right anyway so draw quartz brightly
and we still got the particle system and
it's rendering here okay let's hit f5
and see what happens all right beautiful
so we have this
and oh we still got that particle system
uh we can zoom in and look at this and
it looks pretty good i mean obviously
the aspect ratio is wrong because we're
rendering on
on a square even though the texture is
wider than it is tall
but that's okay we have the texture in
the game engine now we can talk about
the actual texture coordinates
so let's try and draw one of these so
let's pick
maybe this orange bush orange because
that's how i roll and it's a nice kind
of bush and it's kind of in the middle
of the sprite sheet
so this should kind of prove our point
so we need to figure out basically the x
and y coordinate of this
in terms of actual tiles so this is
clearly the first one that's the second
one that's the third one so it's the
third on the x
axis meaning if we start at zero it has
the index two
the real the real point of this is to
identify the pixel offset of this so if
everything here is 128 by 128 the fact
that it has the index 2 here
means that it's going to be 2 times 128
256
that is the offset and you can see that
if we look at this and measure this that
is in fact the starting x offset here
that's the important part now of course
we start from the bottom so
0 1 2 3. so it's 2 on the x and 3 on the
y that is the index of this
that's all we need to know so if we go
back to hazel
let's take a look at the the exact
function that we're using to render this
so i think this is going to be if i just
hit f12
yeah it's the one with texture tiling
factor and it's the not rotated quad
so these are the texture coordinates
that we have someone i think via a pull
request
basically uh rewrote this into like a
for loop and all that stuff which is
fine
we're going to change these texture
coordinates that's basically what we're
going to do so let's take a look at
an example so we want basically the x
index here
to be 2 i think that's what we said and
then y is 3.
right let me just double check that zero
one two three okay good yeah so taking
this we also need the width and height
of the texture
so i'll do sheet width at 2560
and then i think the sheet height was
like 1660
something like that let's take a look
quickly measure this
what are we at oh that's the width okay
height
1664. all right cool 1664.
so we need that and then also we need
the size of each
sprite so i'll say sprite width 128
and then sprite height 128
and then these are all floats let's just
make sure that we write them as floats
doesn't matter too much also just to be
clear in fact it's not already clear
this is obviously temporary code just to
just to prove a point and just to show
you guys how to render this
we're never going to keep this inside a
draw quad function this is
absolutely external stuff and in the
coming episodes we'll be kind of
abstracting i guess all this into some
kind of texture atlas
api that we'll be able to easily use to
provide a single texture and then render
with
some kind of sub-region of that texture
once we have that we need to figure out
our texture coordinates now again this
is going to be fairly easy but let's
kind of
talk about it in depth so our four
texture coordinates at the moment
are 0 0 which is the bottom left 1 0
which is the bottom right
1 1 which is the top right and then 0 1
which is the top
left now what's going to happen is the
bottom left coordinate here
is now going to become whatever x is
times the width of the actual sprites
so in other words this will take this to
be 256 which is the pixel offset
of the bottom left corner or
specifically in this case the left edge
because we're just dealing with the x
axis the left edge of that given sprite
so in other words
if we zoom into this orange bush of ours
then this edge is exactly what we're
calculating right now because that's
going to be this texture coordinate in
fact if i
can draw something here maybe everything
will be better
so that's a terrible color let's make it
like red or something so
this is the kind of coordinate that
we're calculating right now
this is going to be a value between 0
and 1 and we're calculating that value
based on the pixel offset divided by the
entire
width of the image then we're going to
do the right one here then we're going
to do the top
right one and then we're going to do the
top left one and that's going to give us
our four texture coordinates and it's
going to allow us to render this
so let's go back to the code x times
sprite width
and then divided by sheet width okay so
now this is going to give us a value
between 0 and 1.
now let's paste this into here except
this is going to be y
times sprite height divided by sheet
height now the sprites are all square so
we don't really need
sprite width and sprite height but i'm
just keeping this a little bit more
flexible
all right now let's copy and paste this
a whole bunch of times
and change everything so the next one as
i said was the bottom right
meaning we now need to advance x or the
x coordinate by one or you could also
just add sprite with again at the end of
this but what i'm going to do is just
say x plus one here
so x plus 1 is going to apply to both of
these because these are the kind of the
two right edges
and then these bottom two are the two
top
edges so this will be y plus one
and this will also be y plus one okay
that's looking good
now we also need to const x per
these and i think that's pretty much it
so now we should have our correct
texture coordinates unless i've just
made some kind of silly mistake here
so obviously the part here is variable
is well all of these i mean what texture
within that sprite sheet are you
rendering that's what this selects the
sprite sheet width and height is also
dependent on the actual texture this
will be the texture width and height
and in fact i think we could make this a
little bit better this code
by just using texture get width and get
hide instead of
you know hard coding it here but since
everything is a const expression for now
i'll just leave it as is and then of
course sprite width and height is
something that you would need to define
when you actually create that texture
atlas using our api
so that's pretty much that's pretty much
what will happen in the future
anyway now what should happen is every
single quad that's random with this raw
quad function is going to use some kind
of crazy
uv value some kind of crazy texture
coordinates that will in
our case when using this texture map to
just this orange bush
so let's render this and see if we get
the orange bush and you can see that we
do
there is the orange bush and it's got
the particles in front of it
let's maybe try and draw the particles
behind
i think the only real thing to that we
need to do that is
we should probably change the order here
and then i'll also push this like a
little bit forward
all right so now yeah now we have this
in front so we've basically tested to
make sure the alpha's coming through
correctly we even have a bit of a shadow
here
i guess that's kind of hard to see in
here i didn't even know that it had a
shadow let's
just make a new layer and double check
that that's actually there although i'm
sure
that it is yeah okay so we do have this
kind of nice shadow here
cool all right so that is in fact the
bush now it does look a little bit
like pixelated and there's two things
going on here first of all
that's just the way it's going to be
because it's 128 by 128
and it's also trying to be kind of
smooth you can of course
change the filtering to be nearest so if
we go into gl texture
and we change this linear here on the
magnification filter oh magnification
filter is actually set to nearest anyway
so okay it's already on nearest if we
set it to linear
then it would try and interpolate the
values i guess and that would be a
little bit different
all right looks looks pretty much the
same here and that would probably be
because i'm not actually editing the
right function
that's classic okay so let's change the
magnification to linear
on the one that actually loads from a
file this is why we need to
combine everything into like one
function and really clean this up but
anyway yeah so that obviously looks very
blurry because it's actually
trying to linearly interpolate between
the values when magnifying so let's
change that back to nearest
and that's probably something that we'll
stick with now obviously we are kind of
looking at it really zoomed in and
probably be about
this big if it was a real size let's try
a completely different
uh texture here so maybe these stairs so
let's take a look so that's what
zero one two three four five six
seven i think and then from the bottom
zero one two
3 4 5 6. so 7 by 6
is the coordinate for that let's go into
our renderer we'll change
x to b7 y to b6 let's launch that and as
you can see we get our stairs
now you'll notice that this looks
perfectly sharp that's because these are
all just straight lines there's no kind
of
you know it's not attempting to be
smooth it's just trying to be like a
bunch of blocky lines
and that's always going to look good
when you magnify it using nearest
filtering this is basically why
something like minecraft will
look super sharp the textures will look
super sharp even though they're 16 by
16. it's just because they're all
very blocky and they're just being
magnified using nearest filtering and of
course that's just going to snap to the
nearest pixel
and everything is going to be fine okay
cool so now we can render
a whole bunch of different sprites from
within
one texture and that's going to be
really beneficial because
obviously we have more than 32 textures
here we can still all render them with a
single draw call because essentially the
texture so to speak what determines
which of these textures we use
is the texture coordinate that's going
to be in the vertex data
which is something that we stream in
into the vertex buffer
so in other words we're still only going
to be binding a single texture
and we can render all of these sprites
and more in a single draw call but the
more important takeaway here is not the
fact that we have
one draw call it's the fact that we have
zero texture state switches it's all
just one texture
we don't need to rebind other textures
that's really what's going to make
rendering from this sprite sheet
a lot faster anyway i hope you guys
enjoyed this kind of introduction to
sprite sheets
next time we're going to continue on
with this and probably create some sort
of
api so that we can actually properly do
this instead of just putting a bunch of
code into the draw quad function of our
android 2d
because obviously that's very temporary
it's not going to work with like any of
our other textures for example so we'll
do that next time
if you guys have any suggestions for
what this game should be
um i know that's a pretty hard question
and it's probably i need to probably
just sit down and try and design this
thing
but we're still fairly early days with
this like to the point where
we're just trying to figure out how to
get sprites and how to make a level and
then
we'll probably move this out into its
own project and do all of this kind of
necessary like boring stuff that we have
to do in the beginning when we actually
get to
more or less creating some kind of scene
with all these different elements and
stuff like that
that's when it's going to be a lot more
important but if you have any ideas
leave a comment below
also there's discord game engine series
on discord i might even make a special
channel just for this game if it
gets some traction from the testing that
we do but this is good because
this is not just going to end up being
the candidate for testing
our renderer but it's also eventually
hopefully going to grow into being the
candidate for testing
our like interaction and scripting and
ecs and all of that fun stuff
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please hit that like button also
check out patreon.com
is the best place to help support my
channel and everything that i'm doing
here if you guys are interested in more
3d stuff
you can check that out i also did
release a dev vlog the other day
that was um just showing what i've done
in the hazel dev branch check out that
video if you haven't already and
uh yeah i will see you guys next time
where we're going to continue on with
this fun little project
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you